So, I want to take up in August 27, 1915, and this is a very important message about
fusing.
And Jesus gives a very important example to explain fusing.
Louisa said, "I was fusing myself in the most holy will of blessed Jesus, and while
doing this I found myself inside of Jesus, and he told me, 'My daughter, when a soul
fuses herself in my will, it's like when you have two containers full of different fluids,
and one is poured into the other.'
The first remains filled with what the second contained, and the second with the content
of the first.
In the same way, the soul remains filled with me, and I with her is one of the best explanations
you can get of fusing.
And since my will contains sanctity, beauty, power, love, wisdom, etc., by filling herself
with me, fusing and abandoning herself in my will, the soul comes to be filled with my
sanctity, my love, my beauty, my wisdom, etc.
I think you should do this fairly frequently, don't you?
And this in the most perfect way given to a creature.
And I feel I am filled with her, and finding in her my sanctity, beauty, love, etc.
I look at these things as if they were hers, and I like her so much as to become enamored
in such a way as to keep her jealously in my innermost heart.
Enriching her and embellishing her continuously with my divine qualities to be ever more delighted
and enamored.
So the example Jesus gives is two fluids.
So if you take a glass of colourless water and a glass of coloured water, you put the
two together and you cannot separate them.
So September the 20th, 1915.
The fiat must be the sweet knot that binds all the acts of the soul.
In other words, fiat is our response to everything, good, bad and indifferent.
As they say, sweet and sour.
Continuing my usual state, my beloved Jesus made himself seen with scourges in his hands
touching and beating the people, not my image of Jesus, is it yours?
It seemed that the scourges were extending more, and among many things, it seemed that
some were plotting a conspiracy against the church.
Now that's the Marxists and the Freemasons and so on.
And they were mentioning Rome.
This is 1915, and what they're talking about is the infiltration of the church.
Would you like to write that down on your thing?
And they infiltrated the seminary successfully.
And all the homosexuality and abuse of children and everything has all come out of that.
Okay.
And we're living in the days when that bitter fruit has been seen.
So blessed Jesus was afflicted, and as though covered with a black mantle.
Okay, that's morning.
And he said to me, "My daughter, the scourges will make people rise again, and there will
be so many of them that all people will be wrapped in sorrow and mourning.
That is the world war."
Now the last time the whole world in inverted commas was wrapped in mourning and sorrow
was in the 10th plague of Egypt.
And you find that in the Book of Exodus, chapter 12, verses 29 to 34, because at the
time Egypt was the superpower of the day.
And what happened was that the firstborn of every family was killed.
And what Jesus is saying here is that the children of families all over the world will
be killed, which happened.
And since day, that is the human beings, are my members, that is members of the body of
Christ.
Okay.
So that's 1 Corinthians 12, and it's the second half of the chapter.
I can't remember, it should begin around verse 20 or something.
I just haven't looked it up.
And he said, "I'm wrapped in black that is mourning because of them."
Louisa said she was all dismayed, and she prayed Jesus to placate himself, and he in
order to cheer her said, "My daughter, the fiat must be the sweet knot that will bind
all of your acts."
So my will and yours will form the knot.
And know that every thought, word, and act done as tied to my will is one more channel
of communication that opens between myself and the soul.
Look at that, nice and slowly.
So my will and yours must form the knot and know that every thought, every word, every act
done as tied to my will, that is with your will, is that okay?
Is one more channel of communication that opens between myself and the soul?
So the more often we do it, the more these channels of communication are opened with God
between God and ourselves.
And all your acts, if all your acts are tied to my will, not one channel of divine communication
will be closed between you and me.
That's a VIP message, isn't it?
Okay.
Will be closed.
You need to add the D. I've prepared it to see, so I'm reading it as it should read.
So October 2nd, 1915, the soul tries to relieve Jesus from the bitterness caused by the sins
of man because this is the position of the victim soul and it's also part of the ministry
that we have as members of the divine will.
After I had suffered very much because of the privations of my beloved Jesus, it seemed
that he came for a little, in such suffering as to be terrifying, notice she says it seemed,
so it can't have been totally clear.
I plucked up courage and drew near his mouth and after I kissed him, I tried to suckle.
Who knows?
I might manage to relieve him by sucking part of his bitterness.
To my surprise, I was able to draw a little bit of bitterness out of him, which other times
I could not manage to do.
But Jesus was in such suffering that it seemed he didn't realize that it seemed.
He knows everything.
However, after I did this as though stirring himself, he looked at me and he told me, "My
daughter, I can take no more.
I can take no more.
The human creature has reached the brim and fills me with such bitterness that my justice
was in the act of decreeing the general destruction when she insisted on pulling some of the bitterness
out of him."
I want to give you some references, Genesis 15, 16, Exodus 20, verse 5, and Exodus 28,
verse 43.
Matthew 23, verses 25-28, Matthew 24, 12, and Luke 13, 27.
And then Jesus said, "Justice was in the act of decreeing a general destruction of the
human race, but you arrived in time to snatch a little bit of bitterness away from me so
that my justice might be still off."
Now, I want you to notice that in this action of Louisa, she took the decision to approach
Jesus.
She took the decision to try and draw bitterness out of him.
I want you to see her will is completely free.
Is that okay?
However, the chastisements will extend more, Jesus said, "Man incites me.
He disposes me to fill him and almost stuff him with sorrows and chastisement, otherwise
he will not change his mind."
So what Jesus is saying is the issue is repentance.
If the human race would repent, all the chastisements would stop, things would return to normal.
But he's saying, so far, and we're in October 1915, and the World War is now a year old,
he's saying, "Nobody's in any mood for repenting."
So Louisa said, "I hasten to pray him to placate himself, and he without, with a moving tone
said to me, 'Ah, my daughter, my daughter, he disappeared.'
In other words, you have no idea how bad things are."
To October the 25th, 1915, when Jesus can say to a soul, "My life, my mother."
This is quite a wonderful message.
Continuing in my usual state, amid privations and bitterness, I was thinking about the passion
of my beloved Jesus, and he kept repeating, "My life, my life, my mother, my mother."
Surprised I said to him, "What does this mean?"
So this is a very important message now.
Jesus said, "My daughter."
As I feel my thoughts and my words being repeated in you, loving with more love, wanting with
my will, desiring with my desires and all the rest, I feel my life being drawn into you
and my own acts being repeated.
So he feels that he can relive his life on earth through us.
And my satisfaction is so great, I keep repeating my life, my life.
In other words, we are living the Christ's life.
And as I think of what my dear mother suffered, who wanted to take all my pains and suffered
them herself in my place, and as you try to imitate her, praying me to let you suffer
at the pains that souls give me, I keep repeating my mother, my mother.
And you see, Louisa is called to go down the same route as our blessed mother.
In the midst of so much bitterness of my heart because of the many lacerated members of many
souls which I feel within my humanity, my only relief is to feel my life being repeated.
In this way, I feel the members of creatures being knitted again within me.
So this allowing Jesus to relive his life in and through us, and you know, as the prayer
says, he sees through our eyes, he listens in our ears, he speaks through our lips, works
with our hands, goes places with our feet and so on, that allows him to work in us and
through us, and he's very happy when we allow that because he's still able to do his ministry
on the earth.
And because he is now in heaven, he depends on us to let him do this.
So October the 28th, 1915, the life and works of Jesus are seeds sown for souls to harvest.
In other words, it's all there for us, we just have to draw on it and let it do its
wonder in us.
Jesus said, "My daughter, my life on earth was nothing but seeds, sown, seeds sown which
my children will harvest as long as they remain on the same land on which I sow these seeds."
Now, John 4, 35 to 38, Jesus said, "I have sown a harvest and you will reap it."
Acts 8 verses 4 to 8 is the harvest being reaped by the church that Jesus sowed, that's
the harvest of Samaria.
And Jesus talks about his word and everything as seeds Luke 8, 11.
And Jesus said, "According to their attitude for harvesting, my seeds will produce their
fruits."
In other words, it depends on whether we enter into him and take everything that he has and
make them our own in the divine will and give them to souls so that souls can benefit from
them.
Now these seeds are my works, my words, my thoughts and even my breaths.
And if the soul harvests them all, making them her own, she will be enriched in such
a way as to purchase the kingdom of heaven.
But if she doesn't, these seeds will serve as her condemnation.
That's rather interesting, isn't it?
In other words, I've done everything for you.
I have provided everything for you.
You didn't bother.
You didn't bother to benefit even remotely.
So that reminds me of the parable of the talents, you know, and the man with the ten talents
did well, the man with the five talents did well, and the man with the one talent said,
"You didn't have your talent back because you're an almene, you want to benefit from
my work."
And so the Lord said, "Take that and give it to the man with ten talents."
They all said, "Oh, but that isn't right."
He said, "It is right."
He made the most.
He worked the hardest.
And so to him who has more will be given and to him who has not, even that which he has
will be taken away.
That's what Jesus said.
Okay.
So we need to look at the little warning there that we have a responsibility that all of
this is given to us as gift, but we need to actually do something about it.
So November the 1st, 1915, Jesus wants to pour himself out in love.
This morning, my sweet Jesus did not keep me waiting for long.
He came, though panting and restless, and throwing himself into my arms.
He said, "My daughter, give me rest.
Let me pour myself out in love.
If just as once it's outpouring, it can pour itself out with all the peoples.
But my love can pour itself out only with one who actually loves me."
That's rather interesting, isn't it?
With one who is deeply touched by my, it says wounded, with one who is deeply touched by
my love and who is delirious, that means they've really grown hugely.
One who keeps seeking to pour herself out with my love, asking me for more love.
That's typical of the saints.
They're filled with love, they want their capacity expanded, and they want more love,
because it's love alone that the Lord considers important.
Love is the only baggage it can take with you to heaven.
You can't take anything else.
So the more of it you have, the better, particularly if you want first class.
So, and if my love did not find a soul who would let me pour myself out, my justice would
ignite even more.
In other words, if there weren't a few people on the earth who was responding in love to
God, justice would have nothing to hold it back, isn't that frightening?
And would give the last blow to destroy poor humanity.
In other words, the Lord considered the earth worth destroying at the time of the first world
war.
I'd hate to ask him what he thinks now.
So I want to give you Revelation 11, 18.
I will destroy the destroyers of the earth.
Now, if you were to summarize that message in so far, you'd have to say, love can be
repaid by love alone.
That's a statement of John of the Cross, Saint John of the Cross.
Love can be repaid by love alone.
And you know as a parent that the only thing your children can give you that you thoroughly
appreciate is love and gratitude, isn't that right?
And the one criticism of the human race that you get in all of these writings is that we're
ungrateful and we don't love.
We're made in the likeness of God and how you respond to children is the way he responds
to us as well.
Okay, so love is the issue there.
And I want to give you as love as the issue is Matthew 22 verses 34 to 40.
Jesus says, love fulfills the whole law.
And as he was saying this, Jesus kissed me over and over again telling me, I love you
but with an eternal love.
Now the first thing I want to give you there is Jeremiah 31, 3.
I have loved you with an everlasting love and my love is constant plus Jeremiah 31, 3.
The second thing I want to give you is John 15 9.
John 15 9 says, as the Father has loved me, so I have loved you.
Well the Father has loved Jesus absolutely, unconditionally, eternally and so on and so
on.
He says, that's the way I love you as well.
But I love you with an eternal love.
I love you with an immense love.
I love you but with a love that is incomprehensible to you.
I love you with a love that will never have limits nor will ever end.
I love you with the love that you will never be able to match.
Now do you think Louise has gone let him away with that?
No way.
She's gone to try and match him.
But who can say all the titles with which Jesus said he loved me?
And at each title he spoke he waited for my answer, not knowing what to say to him and
not having sufficient titles to match him, I told him, my life, you know that I have
nothing.
She's going to show you here how to respond to the Lord, okay, it's wonderful prayer.
My life she said, you know that I have nothing and whatever I do I take from you and then
I leave it with you again so that my things remaining in you may have a continuous attitude
and life in you while I remain always in my nothingness, okay.
In others we enter into him, we take something from him and we offer it back to him.
That's like the child coming to you and saying, well you know this week I need a little bit
of extra money and you knowing darn well your birthdays in a few days time say to the child
and you shouldn't be spending money like this, it's not good for you and so on and so on.
You keep a straight face and everything.
Anyway, you decide you're giving in and you give the child the money and then two days
later, happy birthday.
And the child thought of this, the child wanted to do this but the child did not have
the ability to do it so you have to give the child the ability to do it and the thing that
is absolutely demonetized is all currencies for you is the child's spontaneous love.
That's the value.
It doesn't matter what the child actually gives you.
It's the spontaneity of the love is of value.
That's exactly what God wants from us when we pray as well.
That we want to love him, we want to respond, we want to do things for him.
So Louisa said, I have nothing in myself, therefore I take your love and I make it my
own and I say to you, I love you with an eternal and immense love.
I love you with the love that is no limits and no end and that is equal to yours.
Now, why can't you say that because I love you with your will.
Once you enter into the divine will then you take his love and you give it back to him
and she says, got it, I met you.
We can only match him by actually entering into his divine will.
I think it's beautiful and I kissed him over and over again and I kept repeating, I love
you.
Jesus became calm, took rest and he disappeared and then coming back he showed me his most
holy humanity all beaten up, wounded and dislocated all blood.
I remained horrified and so this is the result of the next lot of sins thrown at him.
And Jesus said, my daughter, look, I keep within me all the poor, wounded ones, there's
the soldiers and the battle.
It's not our image of World War I that the Lord is out there in the field and he's worried
about every single one of these soldiers but I don't know about you but it does something
for me.
I keep within me all these poor, wounded ones who are under the bullets and I suffer together
with them.
That's Matthew 2540, whatever you do to the least of my brothers you do to me.
I want you to take part in these pains for their salvation.
Now there's your John 159 again, love your neighbor.
As the father has loved me so I have loved you, so you are to love your neighbor.
So in the divine will we give God his glory and praise and everything on behalf of everyone
and we reach out to try and save the people who are being so foolish as to run towards
hell.
And as Jesus transformed himself into me I felt myself agonizing and grieving, I felt
in other words what Jesus felt.
So November the 4th, 1915, the sorrow of the most holy virgin because of the scourge
of war.
As I was in my usual state I found myself outside of myself together with the Queen Mother
and I prayed that she would intercede with Jesus to stop the scourge of war.
I said to her, "My mother, have pity on those poor victims.
Don't you see how much blood, how many members torn to pieces and how many moans and tears?
You are the mother of Jesus, but also our own mother."
So it is up to you to reconcile your children.
I love the mother being ticked off by what she's supposed to do.
And when I was praying her she said she was crying.
But though crying she seemed unyielding.
Now one of the things I love about the works of Maria Valtorta as well as Louisa Picaretta
is that our blessed mother is portrayed as very strong.
We can have a kind of a weak image of how you've only seen her as a plaster cast statue.
Not somebody who had this enormous strength in her.
Even though she was crying she seemed unyielding.
I cried along and continued to pray for peace and my dear mother told me, "My daughter,
the earth is not yet purged."
Now don't forget to see, even though she's the mother of us all, she's in the divine
will deeper than any other creature.
Therefore she feels what is happening to the Lord as a result of all the sins that are
coming.
The people she said are still hardened.
Now a soul who dies hardened is finished because if you're close to grace there's nowhere
in the kingdom of God that you can lend yourself in.
So the thinking of heaven is that it's better to cause you a little pain on the earth and
save your soul than to leave you with your comfort on the earth and then you have horror
for the rest of eternity because you see the thing is if you look at me for a second, time
is like this length and eternity is this length.
So the wise person will go for the eternal fruit rather than just the temporal fruit.
So that's why even though she loves her children she would love to be only all tenderness and
compassion she knows that if they don't get the chastisement they're lost eternally.
And so she's going to let it happen.
Besides she said if the scourge ceases who will save the priests, look at the group she
picks out.
Isn't that incredible?
Who will convert them?
The garment that for many of them covers their lives is so deplorable and even the laity
are disgusted to approach them.
Let us pray.
Isn't that something else?
That's 1915, that's a century ago.
Now what is our lady actually referring to?
I've already told you the infiltration of the church had already started.
And with the infiltration of the church you had the homosexuality and all the sexual
stuff introduced into the clergy.
And so that's why the garment that covers them is deplorable.
They're covered by a garment of sin and not by a garment of grace.
It's already a century ago, is that amazing?
So our blessed mother is portrayed here as a mother who wants her children pure and holy
like herself.
Okay, she's no softy that says mercy is letting them off the hook and letting them get worse.
My dad used to have an expression called tough love, did you have that one as well?
Okay.
Our blessed mother is shown in these writings as a woman who loves with tough love.
She wants your ultimate good, not your present comfort.
I think that's a wonderful image of her.
So November the 11th, 1915, the soul who live in the divine will are other christs.
So there's your VIP again.
If I'm another Christ, then he sees through my eyes, he hears in my ears, he speaks in
my voice, doesn't he?
And so on.
So Louisa said, "This morning I felt such compassion for the offenses that Jesus receives
and for the many poor souls who have the misfortune of offending him, that I would face any pain
in order to prevent sin.
And I prayed and I repaired from the heart, not as from the heart.
Our blessed mother in Medigoria has emphasized for years that we need to pray from the heart,
not just from the lips."
In the meantime, blessed Jesus came.
In the meantime, blessed Jesus came and seemed to carry the same wounds as my heart, but
oh, how much larger, and he told me, my daughter, in issuing the creature in creation, my divinity
remained as though wounded by my own love for love of the creature.
This wound made me come down from heaven to the earth and cry and shed my blood and do
all that I did.
Now, the soul who lives in my will feels this wound of mine vividly as if it were her own.
She cries and she prays and would suffer anything to save the poor, to suffer anything to save
the poor people so that my wound of love may not be exacerbated by the offenses of souls.
And my daughter, these tears, prayers, pains, and reparations soothe my wound and descend
upon my breast like shining gems, and I'd lorry in keeping them on my breast to show
them to my father so as to move him to pity towards creatures.
So a divine vein ascends and descends between these souls and mine.
I want to give you John 1.51 for that, that's Jacob's letter fulfilled.
A divine vein ascends and descends between these souls and mine, which keeps consuming
their human blood, and the more they share in my wound and in my very life, the larger
this divine vein becomes.
It becomes so large that they become other Christs.
And I keep repeating to the Father, I am in heaven, but there are other Christs on the
earth.
Now that's terribly important.
If there are other Christs on the earth, the earth is going to be allowed to go on.
There are other Christs on the earth who are wounded with my same wound, who cry like
me and suffer and pray and so on.
And therefore, we must pour out mercy upon the earth.
Only these who live in my will, who share in my wound, are like me on the earth and will
be like me in heaven in sharing the same glory as my humanity.
Isn't that absolutely amazing?
Yeah.
So it's the people who are living in the divine will are other Christs on the earth.
And they are not only like Jesus on earth, they will be like him forever.
Okay.
So November the 13th, 1915, the necessity for Jesus to give communion to himself before
giving it to others and how the soul must offer her communion.
This is a vital piece of information about receiving Jesus in the Holy Eucharist.
After I had received Holy Communion, I thought to myself, "How should I offer this communion
in order to please Jesus?"
And he told me, "My daughter, if you want to please me, offer this Holy Communion for
others as my own humanity did."
Before giving communion to others, I gave communion to myself.
And I wanted to do this in order to give to the Father the complete glory of all the
Communions of all souls to enclose within me all the reparations for all the sacrileges,
for all the offenses that my humanity would receive in this most Holy sacrament.
Since my humanity enclosed the divine will, it enclosed all reparations of all times.
And since I received myself, I received myself worthily.
So I think one of the things that is very important to do after receiving communion is
to enter into the acts of Jesus, views with him, enter into the acts of Jesus, make them
your own, and offer them in reparation and substitution for all of us who can't receive
him worthily.
You need to be him to receive him worthily.
And so we can do this for all of us, make reparation for everyone.
I think that's very important.
So Jesus said, "I received myself worthily.
And since all the works of souls were divinized by my humanity," look at that.
With my Communion, I wanted to seal the Communion of all souls, otherwise how could the creature
receive God?
Do you see why I make that reparation?
Because how can we receive God?
None of us are fit, no matter how holy or anything else that we think we are.
We're not fit.
So it's terribly important to take his acts in communicating himself and offer them in
reparation and substitution for everybody else, absolutely every.
It was my humanity that opened the door to them and errant for them that they might receive
me.
In other words, it was Jesus's incarnation.
It was the incarnation of the word that enabled this incredible gift to be given to us.
Now you, my daughter, you do it with my will.
You see, the way we're being told quite clearly, and united to my humanity.
In this way, you will enclose everything and I will find in you the reparations of all
and the compensation for everything.
You see why I do it?
And you will also receive my satisfaction.
Even more I will find in you another me.
So if you go to 1 Corinthians 11, 28 to 30, Saint Paul brings out the importance of receiving
Jesus' wordily.
1 Corinthians 11, 28 to 30.
So November the 21, 1915, man forces God to chastise him and to make himself known by
means of justice.
Finding myself in my usual state, Louisa said, "I saw my beloved Jesus for just a little,
and I prayed him for pity's sake to change the decrees of divine justice.
I said to him, 'My Jesus, no more.
My poor heart is crushed in hearing about the many tragedies.
Jesus, enough.
These are your dear images.'
Now that's Genesis 1, 27.
Romans 8, 29.
Colossians 3, 10.
These are your dear images and your beloved children that moan, cry, and grieve under
the weight of the almost infernal instruments.
And Jesus said, 'Am I, daughter, yet all the terrible things that are happening now are
only the sketch of the design.'
I want you to hear that.
These were going to be much worse in World War II and much worse in World War III coming
up.
'These are only the sketch of the design,' he said.
'Don't you see what a large circle I am making?
What will happen when I execute the design?'
At many points they will say, 'Watch this now.
This is prophetic.
Here there was such and such a city.
Here such and such buildings.
Some points will disappear completely.
Time is short.
Man has reached the point of forcing me to chastise him.
He wanted to almost challenge me, now that's the atheism thing, Marxist atheism.
He wanted to almost challenge me, to incite me, and I remained patient.
But all times come to pass.
They did not want to know me by means of love and mercy.
They will know me by means of justice.'
Isn't that frightening?
It's one or the other?
Our choice.
So December the 10th, 1915, the soul must make the prayers, the works, and the sufferings
of Jesus her own so as to have in her power all the good that they produced.
This is terribly important that we enter into him and take everything that he has provided
for us.
Louisa said I was feeling so very afflicted because my sweet Jesus, my life, my all did
not make himself seem.
I was lamenting.
If I could, I would deafen heaven and earth with my lament so as to move him to compassion
for my poor state.
What a great misfortune to know him, to love him, and to remain without him.
Now Louisa will discover in higher volumes that she has said something important here.
Because the tragedy of hell is that at the last second you have seen him and you can't
help but love him when you see him, you can't have him because you decided against him.
The tragedy of purgatory is that you do actually love him and you do know him but for a long
time you can't have him.
That is actually the pain of purgatory and Louisa is going to discover as she goes on
that in these privations she's allowed to experience the pain of the souls in purgatory.
That's actually very important and when she realizes that she won't be sort of saying
you don't love me anymore, do you know what I mean?
She'll realize that she's being allowed to make reparation for them.
To know him, to love him, and to remain without him is an agonizing, terrible pain.
And there ever be a grave or misfortune.
But while I was lamenting, "Blessed Jesus made himself seen in my interior," now that's
Luke 17, 21, "The kingdom of God is within you."
And he told me with a severe look, "My daughter, do not tempt me.
Why this?
I told you everything so as to let you be tranquil.
I told you that when I abstain from coming it's because I have to tighten stronger chastisements
because my justice wants it so.
I even told you the reasons before you would not believe that it was an order to chastise
that I wasn't coming as usual.
Because you did not hear that great chastisements were happening in the world.
Now you do hear them and in spite of this you still doubt, "Why are you tempting me?"
Oops, that's a scolding, isn't it?
Yeah.
In other words, you can go on and on for a while but you've got to stop at some point.
So what I want to do is give you Deuteronomy 6, 16 for this paragraph.
And it says, "Do not tempt the Lord your God."
Matthew 4, 7, "You shall not tempt the Lord your God."
Acts 15, 10, "Why would you tempt the Lord your God?"
So you could see that Louisa is one of the human race.
And so Louisa said I was shaking in seeing and hearing Jesus so severe and in order to
calm me down he changed his look and all kindness he said, "My daughter have courage.
I do not leave you."
That's John 14, 17, John 14, 17.
And I am inside of you.
Now she knows he's inside her, but she doesn't accept that.
Although you do not always see me.
And you must unite yourself always with me.
That's diffusing, okay?
If you pray, let your prayer flow in mine.
Now we have to remember to say those words at the beginning of the Rosary or any other
prayer I want my prayers to flow in your divine will.
It's actually important to say the words.
In this way, all that I did with my prayers, the glory I gave to the Father and the good
that I interceded for all you will do as well, only if you are united with his and in the
divine will.
If you work, so he's going to give three examples, so the first one was prayer, the
second one was work, let your work flow in mine and make it your own so you enter into
him and make everything flow in his.
In this way, you will have in your power all the good that my humanity did which sanctified
and divinized everything.
If you suffer, let your suffering flow in mine and make it your own and in this way,
you will have in your power all the good that I did in redemption.
By this, you will take the three essential points of my life, prayer, work and suffering.
Do you see it?
And as you do so, immense seas of graces will come out of you and will pour out for the
good of all.
Now, do you see what he's saying that when we in the divine will unite our prayer, our
work, our suffering with his immense good is done for all souls past, present and future.
Immense good.
There is his words.
And I will look at your life not as yours, but as mine, that's wonderful.
So January the 12th, 1916, almost all nations have united an offending God and have conspired
against him.
Louisa was lamenting to blessed Jesus because of his usual privations and she cried bitterly.
And Jesus came in a sorrowful state showing how things will get worse and worse.
This made Louisa cry even more and Jesus said, "My daughter, you cry over the present times
and I cry over the future.
I, that's fascinating."
Oh, and what amaze will the nations find themselves to the point that one will become
the terror and the massacre of the other?
Such that they will be unable to get out by themselves.
They will do things as though crazy, as though blind to the point of acting against themselves
and the maze which poor Italy is in how many shocks will she receive.
So I want to give you Amos 3.7.
The Lord never does anything without telling the prophets first.
Remember how many years ago I told you that Italy deserved the chastisement of being
invaded by foreign nations and Louisa told him many times, "Don't let the foreigners
call me."
Do you remember?
This is the plot that they are hatching against Italy.
How humiliated and annihilated she will remain.
She has been too ungrateful to me.
Now watch this.
This is very important.
The two nations for which I had a predilection Italy and France are the ones who have denied
me the most.
Now if you take France, you've got the French Revolution, abolishing Catholicism and so
on, and you have Italy who has just walked away from the faith that there is no attention
to it.
You can go to Rome and you can get 400 empty churches.
The buildings are there.
And they held hands in offending me.
In other words, what one was doing, the other was doing.
Just chastisement.
They will hold hands in being humiliated.
They will also be the ones that will wage war more against the church.
I want to give you Matthew 10, 38.
Matthew 10, 38.
Your enemies will be those of your own household.
My daughter, almost all nations have united in offending me.
They have conspired against me.
What wrong have I done to them?
Do you remember their reproaches of good Friday?
What have I done to you?
Almost all of them deserve chastisement.
But who can say the sorrow of Jesus and the state of violence in which he was in and also
my fright and fear, she said, "I said to Jesus, 'How can I live among so many tragedies?
Either you let me be a victim and spare the people, or you take me with you.'
Now he has told her endlessly that if he spares them, they're not going to repent, and she
still comes back to this all the time.
January 28, 1916, constrained love is the greatest bitterness, and so Louisa has a suspension
of her state of victim.
Louisa said, 'I felt oppressed, and I thought to myself how everything is over, the state
of victim, suffering, Jesus, everything.
I had that the confessor was not well, and therefore it was likely that I would have to
remain without communion.
I felt all the weight of the suspension of my state of victim on the part of Jesus.
As for the guide, the guide is whatever priest is standing in, and there's no name offered.
I had received no order, either in favour or against it.
To this I also added my affliction.
And I remembered that on March of last year when the confessor was not well, and I was
in the same condition Jesus had told me that if I, or one who guides me, would keep me
in the state of victim, he would spare Corrato; therefore new fears, that I myself might be
the cause of some grave trouble also in Corrato.
But who can say all of my apprehensions and bitterness?
There were so many that I felt petrified.
Now my sweet Jesus having compassion made himself seen in my interior, that's your Luke 1721,
and he seemed to have his hand on his forehead all afflicted.
So much so that I did not have the courage to call him.
Almost whispering I just said Jesus, Jesus.
He looked at me, but oh how sad was his gaze.
My daughter he said, "How much I suffer.
If you knew the pains of the one who loves you, you would do nothing but cry.
I suffer for you also because since I do not come very often, my love is constrained and
I cannot pour itself myself out, and in seeing that you too cannot pour yourself out because
you do not see me in seeing you suffer, I suffer more.
And my daughter, constrained love is the greatest bitterness which tortures a poor heart the
most."
Now watch the next sentence, please call her it if you have.
If you could remain quiet while suffering, I would not suffer so much.
Does that deserve an ouch?
Okay.
She doesn't remain quiet does she?
If you could remain quiet when suffering, I do not suffer so much.
But if you afflict yourself and worry in your suffering, I fidget and become delirious.
And I am forced to come and pour myself out and to let you pour yourself out since my pains
and yours are sisters.
Why?
Because they're one.
And besides, your state of victim is not over.
My works are eternal, and it's not without a just reason that I suspend them.
Though without making them end, besides, I look at things in the will.
Now he's told her that now for eleven volumes, that it's in your will.
It's whether your will is conformed to the divine will that he cares about, not the fluctuations
of your emotions, okay?
I look at things in the will, so you are as you used to be because your will has not changed.
And if you do not have sufferings, you are not the one who receives harm.
Rather, it's the people that do not receive the effects of your pains, that is to be spared
the scourges.
It's the same as with those people who occupy public offices or government positions for
a given time.
Even when they retire from these positions, they receive a life salary.
Should I be outdone by creatures?
I don't know.
If those are given pensions for life, I give them for eternity, I like that one, isn't it?
Therefore, you must not be concerned about the pauses that I make.
And then, why do you fear?
Have you forgotten how much I loved you?
The one who guides you will be prudent, knowing how things are and how they have been.
And I will have regard for Corrato.
As for you then, whatever might happen, I will hold you tightly in my arms.
She's supposed to calm down after that.
So January the 30th, 1916.
This is all about surrender.
When the soul lives completely in the divine will ring the word completely, that's 100%.
Everything she does is reflected in Jesus, and everything Jesus does is reflected in
her.
It's another very important message.
So Louisa said, "I was fusing all of myself and my beloved Jesus."
And while I was doing this oncoming, Jesus fused all of himself in me.
Have you underlined that?
Jesus fused all of himself in me.
And he told me, "This is mutual fusing.
Jesus's communion is mutual, I communion with him and he communes with me."
Isn't that right?
Union with God is mutual, you and me and I and you.
So Jesus said, "My daughter, when the soul lives completely in my will," now that's
your Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
If she thinks her thoughts are reflected in my mind in heaven, if she desires, if she
speaks, if she loves, everything is reflected in me, and everything I do is reflected in
her.
It's like when the sun is reflected in glass, now see the example that he gives.
I want you to notice the examples, they're all very simple.
I can see another sun in it, completely similar to the sun in the heavens with this difference.
The sun in the heavens is fixed and remains always in place, but the image of the sun
in the glass moves.
Isn't that right?
Now, "my will crystallizes the soul," crystallized means he's looking at the glass.
My will crystallizes the soul, and everything she does is reflected in me.
Okay, the word that lasts, he's the sun.
And I wounded and enraptured by these reflections, sent her all of my light.
I want to give you Matthew 5, 17 there.
So as to form another sun in her.
So it seems that there is one sun in heaven and another one on earth, what enchantment
and what harmonies between them.
How many goods are poured out for the good of all, but if the soul is not fixed in my
will, that means you're in and out, in and out, in and out.
It can happen to her as to the sun which is formed in the glass, which is only a temporary
passing sun, okay.
After a while, the glass remains in the dark and the sun in the heavens remain alone.
So let's spread the people who are in and out of the divine will.
In other words, they do the divine will until their own will says, "It's my turn," and
they go and do their own will.
Then they realize, "I should be back in the divine will, but I've done my own and I got
my satisfaction anyway, so it's okay.
I'll go back into the divine will when I'm not being challenged."
You haven't heard that yet, haven't you?
Okay, very important because that's the temptation of all of us, is to do the divine will when
everything's fine, but when the challenge comes, do my own.
Then I say, "Okay, I'll come back into your will, but you've missed the boss, and we
mustn't miss the boss to train the boat and the airplane, because then you're not in the
divine will at all."
Okay, hence you're told in the early volumes that really your motto should be, "Not my
will, but die and be done," and the challenge is when things go against you.
And the moment things go against you, you must say it before you do anything.
"Not my will, not my will, but die and be done."
And when you've established it's not going to be my will, but then you will take a different
approach to whatever the challenge is.
Instead of doing what the lower nature wants, you'll do what God wants, it's very different,
and the results are very different.
Okay.
So February the 5th, 1916, "Scourges to the world and great trials for the few good people."
Now the expression "few good people," the word we usually use is remnant.
So for the remnant, then things are going to be tough.
So Louisa said, "I continuing my days being afflicted, especially because of the almost
continuous threats of Jesus that the scourges will spread more.
Last night then I remained terrorized.
I found myself outside of myself and I found my afflicted Jesus.
I felt reborn to new life and finding him, but no, as I was about to console him some
people snatched him away and reduced him to bits.
While heartbreak, what fright I threw myself on the ground, close to one of those pieces,
and a voice from heaven resounded in that place.
And this message is very important.
The message said firmness, courage to the remnant, the few good people.
Now firmness, we also use the word stability and courage.
May they not move in anything."
Now this is extremely important because the society we're living in wants us to move from
the Ten Commandments and to say that what they're doing is right.
You can't.
God's will is immutable.
God's will is eternal.
But then they'll persecute you, you see, telling you you're intolerant.
They're already at that, aren't they?
So firmness and courage are terribly important.
They must not move in anything.
May they not neglect anything.
They will be exposed to great trials both from God and man.
I find that interesting, from God in order to enable us to be purified and grow in holiness
and make reparation and from man because they'll hate us.
Only through faithfulness they will not stagger and they will be saved.
So faithfulness, I want to give you Revelation 2, 10.
You get the prize of victory.
Faithfulness, I want to give you Titus 1, 19, 1, 9, sorry, Titus 1, 9.
I want to give you Hebrews 12 verses 1 to 4.
And they will not stagger and they will be saved is Mark 13, 13.
And Jesus continues, "The earth will be covered with scourages never before seen."
In other words, the never before seen situation of the whole world turning against God requires
reactions from heaven never before seen.
Man will try to destroy the Creator, to have a God of their own, to satisfy their whims
at the cost of any slaughter.
Now that's what happened in the Bolshevik revolution, the Marxist Communist absolutely
abolished God, abolished religion and the people had to worship the state.
And they weren't the only other countries followed that as well.
And with all of this not attaining their purpose they will arrive at the most awful brutalities.
But that's Jesus speaking, it's not a commentation.
Everything will be terror and fright, he said.
After this, Louisa said, "I found myself inside of myself and I was shaking."
The thought of how they had reduced my beloved Jesus gave me death.
I wanted to see him at any cost even for one instant to see what had happened to him and
Jesus always good came and I calmed down, may he always be blessed.
So I'll give you one more.
So Martin II 1916, what God contains in his power the soul contains in her will.
Now you need to put VIP about ten times on this one.
This is massive.
I continue my most bitter days Louisa said, "Blessed Jesus comes only rarely and if I lament
either he answers with the sob of crying or he says to me, 'My daughter, you know that
I do not come often because the chastisements are encroaching more and more.
Why do you lament?'
But I reached such a point that I could not take anymore and I burst into tears," she
said, "in order to calmly and strengthen me Jesus came and I spent almost the whole
night with him.
He kissed me and caressed me and sustained me and he threw himself into my arms to take
rest.
That's all song of song stuff.
He showed me the terror among the different peoples and some would run away in one direction
and some in another.
I also remember that he told me, 'My daughter, what I contain in my power the soul contains
in her will.'
So I look at all the good that the soul really wants to do as if she had really done it.
My comment in my own book is, 'Wow, and I want to give you an illustration,' and that
is that Saint Therese of Lesus in her convent wanted to be a priest and she wanted to be
a missionary and she wanted to be this, that and the other, so that she could do an enormous
amount for souls.'
And the Lord said, 'Done.'
If you want it, I'll do it.
That's exactly what he says to us in divine will.
And so we need to grasp at some point the enormity of the privilege and the responsibility
we have to pray for all kinds of situations.
I have will, he said, 'And power, and if I want, I can.'
On the other hand, the soul cannot do many things.
That's your John 15.5, without me you can do nothing, okay?
But her will compensates for power.
In this way, she keeps becoming more like me and I keep enriching her with all of the
merits that her good will contains and that all that her will wants to do.
We just need to really try and get a handle on that.
And then he added, 'My daughter, when the soul gives herself completely to me, that's
the will handed over and it's Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.'
And giving yourself completely to Jesus means 24, 7, 3, 6, 5.
Is that okay?
No time out.
I establish my dwelling in her, 1 Corinthians 3, 16.
Many times I like to shut everything and be in the shade.
Other times I like to sleep and I place the soul as a century that she may not allow anyone
to come to bother me and to interrupt my sleep.
And if necessary, she has to face the bothers herself and to answer for me.
Other times I like to open everything and let in the wind, the coldness of creatures.
The darts of sins that they sent me and other things and the soul must be content with everything.
Now this means that the person living in this deep communion with God sometimes feels the
coldness or the warmth or the trouble or the difficulty, but it's not your own.
You're being allowed to experience what Jesus experiences from souls on the earth and you
have to know I unite all of this with the sufferings and the reparations and everything
of Jesus in his will for the salvation of all souls.
Is that okay?
The soul must be content with everything.
In fact, St. Therese of Lissue gave a most wonderful response to this and she said, "I
choose what you choose for me."
That's the complete surrender of the will.
"I choose what you choose for me," that's St. Therese.
So the soul must be content with everything.
She must let me do whatever I want.
And more, she must make my things her own.
If I were not free to do what I want, I would be unhappy in that heart.
If I had to be careful to make her feel how much I enjoy, but unwillingly hide from her
how much I suffer, where would my freedom be?
In other words, if there's going to be union between two persons, everything, the good,
the bad and the indifferent, of both persons are shared, isn't that right?
Everything is in my will, he said.
If the soul takes the divine will, she takes the whole substance of my being.
Now you have the answer to the question, "What is divine will?"
It's the whole substance of the being of God.
If the soul takes the divine will, she takes the whole substance of my being and encloses
the whole of me within herself.
And as she goes on doing good by having the substance of my life within herself, she makes
that good come out of my very self.
And since it comes out of me, it runs like a ray of light for the good of all souls.
You're wonderful, okay, so I'm going to leave it there for tonight.